welcome to this video got two extra yard
oh okay I never played this guy before
maybe do a king's indian for good
measure do something else come on give
me some exciting lion yeah then can I do
let's let's just ignore that and play
this nakamura variation we're like a
strong everything including the kitchen
sink but it's destroyed on the queenside
i'm not sure if Knight f6 is right to be
honest hmm yeah okay it will probably
not be decisive maybe I should have gone
for some other move order yeah why does
very quickly on the queenside f3 is
normal somehow is not playing that kind
of surprised okay yeah let's push this I
know he has not played f3 yet but don't
really see any other useful move
ok let's continue he might know now he
cannot take their plane I'd be five I
have night XP farm and just as I say it
he plays it anyway yeah I mean the thing
is he also has a night XD seven
if I go 98 this kind of passive move we
can still no I cannot take this seven
but you might have come on I have to
have to play somewhat and yeah you know
what I was thinking can I go nite g3l is
this totally totally idiotic yeah
probably if I return to f6 I mean I can
also i take contigo I can take you five
it's a home no idea what this is
it's not only not such a great idea for
why to give give their give the pawn
yeah Mina see for ponds what I was
trying to say okay so yeah okay I
probably have to take right so back and
probably t6 yeah how bad is that I don't
know it it looks kinda weird but I'm not
totally sure how bad it is for black
probably it's not good not good for
black but it's still feels really messy
okay he's going for buffet if it's
probably a good move him
yeah yeah okay so he's somehow combining
Bishop e3 and d6 I was thinking b5 was
the idea I don't know this also looks
dangerous for me because there's somehow
Bishop c4 is always somewhere but but
still I don't I don't know if t6 was
right I have to go out of this diagonal
at some point
cannot stay with this Bishop c4 over
over my head all the time right I don't
think I'm so in such terrible shape here
maybe maybe a computer will totally tell
me apart but it is still I'm still
fairly and messy for one I can also play
stuff like Queen a to ya come on let's
let's harass him there with this hanging
bishop yeah but that is a bathroom with
him we can play Bishop before even
intending Bishop c4 or that one
and it was really cilia tweenager this
kind of pseudo active move that is
really nothing really totally bad oh
what a bad game really bad player black
okay i need to go into a full fledge
swindling mode some stuff here with be
sure to d4 Knight h5 and I can take them
95 Roxy seven
I don't know I have to hope for some
kind of miracle anyway
then green g 6 which is really not
working at all but that isn't that this
is a little bit dangerous for what nah I
don't know this is this is not easy King
h1 I mean I can maybe just take h2 I
definitely can take edge 2 i'm not sure
how good it is but yeah what else I mean
yes to play King edge one time morning
taking Bishop b5 will loose and this I'm
not sure what it will yeah I have this
check Sister Sister the real issue check
check check late yeah it's this is the
story of the Kings Indiana black is
playing like a total idiot and then
there's some Hail Mary attackable which
succeeds I don't know yeah I've lost so
many games with white thinking that the
black player must be totally totally
it's your take i 10 then you get this
this kind of kind of counter attack yeah
I'm Kim this is really not a good
position anyway I thought it is
sufficiently I don't know complicated
let's say that this is totally idiotic
and night see force even stronger yup
trapping the queen with Luke a 1 yeah
a queen a 2 was like completely idiotic
yeah and this is just just not working
but when does it start to get get
problematic yeah he am the captcha is is
really wrong and now the computer is
getting down to just a slight advantage
King edge one the only move and now it
says night III this is losing you too
Luke f2 yeah but okay I have to play he
has got 20 seconds what can you do
Andrew q1 now I can archaic I could have
taken only four with the Queen but now
this is also winning of exactly this is
a check made chechik yeah and it's it's
made anyway I'm this is checkmate also
made yeah a very lucky victoria this is
this sort of comes with the territory of
the king's indian sometimes you you make
some silly moves and somehow you get get
a fishy counter-attack and then
sometimes really succeeds I don't know
it's weird alright thanks for watching